[Applause]
joy explodes on the main boulevard in
tennis prod are they still bedding
democracy thousands of sites supporters
celebrating the men would they say can
keep alive the spirit of the 2011
revolution young people showed they can
use their vote to change the system
several political parties gave a lot of
money to win this presidency but the
people and the young ones who were a
part of the revolution in 2011 did it
again a new revolution this time with a
ballot choice aid is a low profile
conservative law professor he campaigned
for radical decentralization and pledged
to build a democracy that all Tunisians
including the youth can have a sane we
will face up to all the challenges with
our blood and sweat and that will power
especially the economic and the social
ones because the Tunisian people expect
solutions in this respect but he will
have to work with the Parliament where
no party has a clear majority his
supporters though are hopeful that the
independent outsider can convince and
succeed let's talk about this more now
at TW aya Abraham in the studio with me
this morning good morning I a nice to
see you again you know we're looking at
some interesting polls to show 90% of 18
to 25 year olds voted for a Syed
what's his appeal with young voters I
think it's because he's not a politician
I think young people have had enough of
traditional Tunisian politicians and
crisis and crisis exactly the opposite
of that he's a law professor people say
that he's a newcomer to politics it's
true that he's not a career politician
but he's been on the scene for quite
some time as a constitutional law
analysis it appears in the media quite
regularly he was also involved in the
drafting of the 2014 Constitution he's
also you know really portrayed himself
as someone who's not seeking power we
can see this in the way that he has run
this campaign a very very Spartan
campaign if you
not a lot of advertising hasn't relied
so much on an external funding he
notably did not do any campaigning in
the second phase of the election because
his opponent was in prison and you know
as a constitutional law professor he
knew full well that you know should he
win his up his opponent could then
appeal it saying that he wasn't able to
campaign and as such he refrained from
campaigning and still he won this
landslide
I think this anti-corruption spirit that
he has really appeals to young voters
who had enough established politician
you know and knowing the constitutional
ins and outs as being one of the fathers
of the 2014 constitution of courses will
help him with the the divided Parliament
we're looking at right now no party has
a majority can he get his goals his
priorities through with a divided
Parliament well yes and no I mean we
have to really understand the role of
the president in Tunisia's governance
the president unlike the president's
role before the Arab Spring he has
limited powers his powers are limited to
foreign policy and defense the
Parliament is really the one that has a
lot of power to approve laws however the
President does have sort of some
influence to set the tone of the
government most notably the last
president was the one who proposed that
Tunisia consider an equal inheritance
law he had no power to approve it but he
could initiate it and then it would go
into Parliament so he people inheritance
law for women and for men and women most
notably and you know that that met that
was met with a lot of resistance but the
President had the power to sort of
initiate that debate so he does have
power to to initiate the debate but you
know it is still limited but I think you
know he isn't independent and with this
Parliament really being uncharted
territory for the Arab world with so
many independence may be there this new
spirit will inspire some sort of
unprecedented cooperation this election
has definitely been a surprise and so on
many levels and that means maybe the
government will be as well okay
hopefully there's more pleasant
surprises ahead we'll be following this
very closely ayah thanks for that